ryan reynolds and rob mcelhenny the new
owners of wrexham afc
this grass is like cashmere is this real
like at first like anyone she was like
wait what like what how what does this
entail i mean what's gonna happen when
you you know go down this rabbit hole
because she knows me i don't you know
then i know rob's the same way we don't
really do anything half measured you
know we sort of go all in
yes even ryan's wife blake lively wasn't
sure he made a wise business decision to
live out his ted lasso moment and buy a
wrexham afc the biggest challenge is a
community looking around going what are
these two guys doing here but following
their takeover last year she's become a
bigger fan than him but she's obsessed
with wrexham i mean she would be more
obsessed with with wrexham and it's
possible promotion than i am now ryan
and rob's purchase of the oldest
football club in wales is the subject of
a new docu-series called welcome to
wrexham is that the gym it will be the
gym
and who better to ask advice on how to
run a team in the english football
league than from a legend of the
beautiful game david beckham another
benefit of being friends with ryan is
that he's friends with everybody and so
the the idea of learning the rules of
football from one of the greatest
footballers in the history of the sport
is a pretty it's a pretty good aspect
yeah got to speak with him a lot before
this experience and certainly during it
as well and i got a lot of tips from
them that that have been incredibly
helpful yeah it's been it's been pretty
amazing